[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
wir sind gerade mit dem träger partner
richtig leckere torte gemacht ohne
sommer hunger bekommen und deswegen
gibt's heute für euch ein one ford
rezept weil dort rezepte einfach super
schnell gehen und man kann im prinzip
alle zutaten rein machen die man zu
hause hat oder sie war eben kurz
besorgen kann
wir machen heute ein nudelholz rezept
und zwar so ein bisschen asiatisch
angehaucht mit hähnchen mit gemüse und
mit ein bisschen kokosmilch steige ich
davon noch mal die zutaten für das wort
gerät brauche ich drei esslöffel
kokosfett habe ich zwei zwiebeln eine
knoblauchzehe 1 ingo stück drei paprika
in rot gelb und grün
zwei esslöffel mehl drei
hähnchenbrustfilets etwas sojasauce 150
bis 200 gramm zuckererbsen ein paar
gewürze und zwar jeweils einen teelöffel
salz curry paprikapulver und chili eine
dose kokosmilch 400 gramm etwa 600
milliliter wasser 500 gramm nudeln ich
habe hier panel und ein paar
frühlingszwiebeln ich fange jetzt zuerst
einmal an mit dem gemüse das jetzt klein
geschnitten dafür nämlich jetzt zuerst
einmal die paprika
[Musik]
die paprika jetzt kurz zur seite und mit
viel knoblauch und ingwer und schreibt
die alle in wirklich
als nächstes steht zuckererbsen und die
werde ich jetzt nur dritte und zum
schluss noch das fleisch in streifen
schneiden
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich alles vorbereitet und
jetzt kann ich das kokosfett bereit in
einen großen topf geben
da kommt jetzt das fleisch angebraten
[Musik]
jetzt kommen auch das mehl mit dazu und
das findet später die soße und das
kokosfett passt jetzt nicht nur
geschmacklich zum gericht sondern man
kann das auch super toll erhitzen
deswegen eignet sich sehr gut zum braten
jetzt kommt das fleisch raus und zwar
auf einen frischen teller
und dann kann ich hier in der pfanne die
zwiebeln und das gemüse anbraten
magier fußballspiel spanischen freunden
gespielt
der hausschlüssel bitte mit jetzt kommt
das fleisch zurück in die pfanne oder in
den topf besser gesagt auch die alle
auch alle anderen zutaten also die wo
die gewürze kokosmilch die ist oben
immer so ein bisschen fester und ihm
kommt die flüssigkeit setzt sich gern
oben ab und jetzt auch noch das wasser
da gebe ich jetzt aber erstmal nur 400
milliliter mittelrhein und den rest
spare ich mir auch falls noch flüssig
und benötige
das ganze muss jetzt aufgekocht werden
und mit geschlossenem deckel muss es
dann je nach model sorte so etwa 10 bis
15 minuten gekocht werden
und ja dann gleich unser fertiges modell
gericht
[Musik]
das essen ist jetzt fertig ich habe den
topf vom herd runtergezogen und nochmal
ordentlich durchgeführt und natürlich
könnt ihr dann nach belieben noch ein
bisschen nach witzen auf jeden fall
würde ich ein bisschen sojasauce mit
dazugeben gibt dem ganzen noch mal ein
bisschen mehr geschmacks die mädels zu
mir an ihre freundin elia die sitzen am
tisch und warten auf das essen wobei der
ein paar noten ohne soße also meine
mädels ist bei ihrem nudeln mit soße ich
muss noch ein bisschen und pfeffern und
dann wird das ganze schon serviert
ich habe es eben schon probiert als ich
mich richtig sehr lecker vor allem hat
man es schnell gemacht und ihr könnt
wirklich an zutaten mit rein geben was
ihr möchtet zum servieren einfach in
einen teller gute schützen kindchen fürs
foto und dann am besten noch die
frischen frühlingszwiebel mit drauf und
dann könnt ihr das essen servieren
und falls jetzt auch lust bekommen habt
auch dieses leckere wort rezept dann
geht doch mal auf cd blog.de fitness.de
und schaute einfach immer nach den
zutaten und ich wünsche euch ganz viel
spaß beim nachmachen bis zum nächsten
mal tschüss kommt jetzt gibt's essen
trittin
[Musik]